j'aime beaucoup la cérémonie des césar
je n'ai jamais manqué ça m'émeut ça me
fait rire ça me touche ça me bouleverse
je suis heureuse parfois fâchée je
m'énerve je m'embrouille je m'offusque
mais souvent je me réjouis
[Musique]
c'est sur moi que c'est tombé cette
année et j'ai dit un oui franc et massif
dès que canal+ et l'académie me l'ont
proposé ne me demandez pas pourquoi j'ai
dit oui je m'amuse beaucoup à préparer
cette soirée a essayé de rassembler un
maximum de gens différents
exigeant beau intéressant sexy pour
raconter au mieux ce qui est notre
cinéma français il y en a plusieurs à
écrire ni à roschdy zem qui en tant que
président c'est lui qui a la charge il
discourait me semble la plus importante
mais je lui fais confiance parce que
c'est pas seulement un grand artiste est
aussi un mec très intelligent sensible
et avec un point de vue très personnel
sur les choses donc j'ai hâte de savoir
ce qu'il aura à nous dire cette année
moi je suis censé en tant que m6 ouvrir
la cérémonie en disant des trucs ce que
je vais faire ce qui va être chouette
cette année c'est que je pense que les
gens qui vont gagner ils auront des
choses à dire et j'espère qu'il y aura
la plus grande variété de discours
j'espère que chacun se sentira bien
libre d'exprimer ce qu'il a à dire
comme il a envie de le dire pour moi
c'est ça qui sera sexy si c'est
éclectique et si c'est vrai
le plus important c'est que l'académie
des césar qui a été donc complètement
refonder le statufier même s'il ya
encore beaucoup de choses à faire
puisque les statuts tout et on travaille
ça prendra un an ou deux de refaire
complètement les statuts et le règlement
intérieur on peut déjà vous annoncer que
l'académie strictement paritaire sa
présidence son bureau son ca son
assemblée générale
pas encore le collège des votants ça ça
prendra un peu plus de temps mais ça le
sera définitivement et c'est une très
bonne nouvelle
du coup très cher très cher moi très
cher laurent lafitte blanche gardin un
bras benjamin biolay un gouffre est-ce
qu'on est sensible aux prix bas oui
sinon on ferait pas les césar mais en
fait marrant parce que je pense que
meilleure actrice ou meilleur film
personne n'y croit tout à fait dire ça
n'existe pas disons que c'est un élan
d'enthousiasmé vers quelqu'un je pense
que c'est très joyeux de gagner je ne
sais pas ce que ça fait de gagner
alors j'ai perdu beaucoup il ya des gens
qui ont perdu plus que moi il ya des
gens qui ont encore plus de nominations
et aussi peu de césar c'est à dire 0
mais ouais je pense que c'est très
agréable de gagner
c'est bien d'être dans une salle de
music-hall c'est bien parce qu'il ya
benjamin c'est bien parce qu'il n'aura
son orchestre
c'est bien parce que ça raconte le
spectacle vivant c'est bien parce que
c'est une vieille salle qui a une
histoire jour-là pour plein de raisons
ça va être bien d'être là bas je vais
vous dire un souvenir qui se raconte pas
l'année d'un prophète j'avais remis le
césar du meilleur scénario donc à
jacques audiard et ses scénaristes et
moi je suis vous savez je suis
maintenant et donc je peux pas tenir une
soirée entière sans fumée et j'étais pas
la seule j'ai rencontré tarime et
jacques audiard je le connaissais déjà
mais on s'est retrouvé à trois fume une
clope dans les chiottes du châtelet nous
devons tout petit comme ça c'était ma
première rencontre avec star et c'était
pas du tout la dernière tripoli disait
il faut bien traiter nos morts je trouve
qu'il a raison
cette année on avait des disparitions
terrible plein de gens merveilleux qui
ont fabriqué ce cinéma qu'on aime
j'espère qu'on leur dira au revoir
dignement je sais pas si 2021 sera
tellement muc 2020 donc arrêtons de
juger et de fustiger 2020 les son
arrivée sa petite soeur et faisant les
bilans en 2022
en vrai on s'en souviendra
drunk j'ai adoré ce film est ce qu'il
raconte c'est quand même génial d'écrire
un film pour faire la promotion de
l'alcool aussi simple que ça mais le
point départ c'est ça j'ai adoré
adolescente
j'adore tout simplement noir j'avais
voté un peu plus massivement pour lui
parce que je trouve que c'est évidemment
une comédie mais c'est un film qui mit
en scène quand même il ya des partis
pris qui sont chouettes et puis surtout
ça très drôle avec une pléiade d'acteurs
tous plus géniaux et les uns que les
autres mais c'est quand même un film
très fort contre la simplification des
choses et de la pensée je suis retourné
en salle beaucoup au cinéma au théâtre
j'y suis retourné pendant la courte
fenêtre qu'on a eues entre les de
confinement et j'ai été bouleversée mais
a vraiment de voir des salles pleines
autant que faire se peut un siège sur
deux des gens masqués tout ça mais j'ai
senti la ferveur du public des
applaudissements et un son que je
n'avais jamais entendu
moi je suis assez optimiste tout comme
spielberg je pense que rien n'est sûr à
la salle c'était très beau de voir mon
les gens sont prêts est ok pour partager
la beauté l'émotion la joie la rage la
colère va tout ce que provoque le
spectacle des gens ils sont là en france
on a de la chance
et n'oublions jamais que le public
français il fait exister des artistes
qui dans leur propre pays ne rencontre
pas le public
le public français il existe et et
j'aime bien parfois je suis pas d'accord
avec lui parce qu'il fait des bida des
films que j'adore et il fait des succès
à des films que je n'aime pas mais
globalement il a quand même sa propre
indépendance il choisit des films qui
sont pas forcément ceux les plus
attendus à qui il offre des succès
populaires
c'est une histoire qu'on écrit en commun
quand même avec ce public là ça m'a
rassuré en fait de voir les gens dans
les salles et ça m'a plu
la lumière revient toujours on sait
j'espère que la fois l'énergie le
courage l'inventivité la créativité ne
sera pas tué par cette année fatigante
on y va on y va pas vous avez le droit
vous n'avez plus le droit la culture a
été très très large éprouvé quand on dit
ça on oublie pas les restaurateurs on
n'oublie pas le tourisme on n'oublie pas
tous ceux qui souffrent à côté mais
c'est pas parce que d'autres souffrent
qu'on ne peut pas exprimer notre
souffrance elle est réelle je suis
optimiste et du cid
mais je suis optimiste